[Music]
on this Thursday night let's talk about
more layoffs at Bell Media they have
overseen the Inc craif foration of local
news deep cuts at CTV News what's being
lost and why curbing car thieves what's
the plan to stop them and will it work
battle for the ballot the US Supreme
Court about to decide whether Donald
Trump can run for president again plus
Palestinians and Jews living side by
side in Israel it's a rare ability today
to see both sides The Village serving as
a model for
peace global national with Donna freezen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with a troubling day for
Canadian media for the second time in
less than a year there has been another
sweeping round of layoffs at Bell Media
leading to the cancellation of multiple
CTV newscasts across the country parent
company BCE Inc is slashing 9% of its
Workforce eliminating about 4,800 jobs
ctv's Flagship public affairs program W5
is being axed and many local CTV
newscasts have already vanished 45
Regional radio stations in BC Ontario
Quebec and Atlantic Canada are being
sold off Bell Media blames declining ad
revenues and overregulation by the
crtc but BC's Premier today called it
reprehensive ible corporate
greed they bought them
up uh like corporate
vampires they sucked the life out of
them laying off
journalists uh they have overseen the in
craif foration of local news Mackenzie
gray looks at the impact on jobs and on
Canadian journalism in our top story
tonight BCE is the parent company it's
become an unsavory tradition roughly
4800 uh jobs just eight months after
massive layoffs Bell Media is talking
about more Cuts this is CV news at
weekday lunch hour in 6 p.m. weekend
newscast cancelled in virtually every
single CTV Market 24 broadcasts in total
90 hours of weekly local news replaced
one more question with syndicated game
shows I think it's quite clear Bella is
moving further and further from one to
the news uh particularly local news
they're just not interested the company
also selling off 45 radio stations many
in British Columbia irking the premere
the fact that they cannot find it
possible with all of their mbas to
operate a few local news stations have
spec dozens of senior journalists also
laid off you can watch that entire
documentary as well in W5 one of
Canada's longest running television
programs has lost its time slot I have a
significant concern that we're watching
democracy frankly erode right before our
very eyes Bell's parent company declined
an interview request but told the
Canadian press they blame the 4800
layoffs on a poor regulatory environment
last year they asked Canada's
Independent Media regulator to remove
any requirements to air local news and
they also want a bigger share of the100
million Google will pay media companies
through the online news act a framework
sources tell Global News B aggressively
lobbied the federal government including
the Heritage minister to implement we
hope that those big companies are going
to hold their end the bargain what if
they what if they don't subsidize news
BCE made $435 million in profit last
quarter alone but blamed a $40 million
loss in their media division to force
further slashing a rationale that
doesn't pass the smell test for this
former CTV National News correspondent
BCE has made the decision that news is
not important of enough of a value to
let it affect our stock price but the
stock dropped nearly 4% today as it
flirts with 52 we low there was one
positive for shareholders though Donna
BCE raised its dividend for the 20th
straight year this time on the back of
massive layoffs McKenzie thanks how to
combat the escalation in auto theft was
top of mind at a daylong summit meeting
in Ottawa the head of the RCMP calls the
scale of thefts in Canada unprecedented
Federal officials say a vehicle is
stolen somewhere in this country every 6
minutes resulting in roughly $1 billion
in annual losses David Aken reports on
whether the summit came up with workable
plans to stop it there's an awful lot to
talk about today a first ofit kind
Summit to deal with the rapid rise of
car thefts a low-risk high-reward
criminal Enterprise fueled by new
technologies that criminals are using to
defeat high-tech anti- theft devices in
modern vehicles in a lot of cases these
vehicles are selling for double the
retail value if they were sold here in
Canada Federal ministers use the summit
to boast about what Ottawa has already
done outlawing for example some of the
gadgets criminals use to break into cars
or giving Ontario $121 million to fight
the problem and boosting the budget of
the Canada Border Services Agency by $28
million and more funding might be on the
way we'll have something to say and I
mentioned this to my friend commissioner
DM something to say about increased
investments in the RCMP and their
policing partners the Trudeau government
has boosted the maximum sentence for car
theft from 18 months to 2 years but
observers said that extra six months
it's not any deterrent the criminal code
needs to be strengthened so that there
are real consequences for vehicle
thieves we need to see stiffer penalties
we need to stop these criminals and the
Prime Minister himself hinted his
government would act on that we're also
looking at further strengthening
penalties for anyone who participates in
auto theft while his ministers talk
tough to organize crime we say time's up
Justin Trudeau is not worth the crime
Federal politicians also use the Forum
to take veiled shots at an opposition
leader Pierre POV who is clearly getting
under their skin we're convening this
Summit because Canadians need serious
action a catchy slogan won't stop auto
theft with lines like this secure our
ports and lock up the car thieves the
summit also heard that one of the most
important things that can be done is is
to share police intelligence with nonp
police actors that would be shipping
companies Railways Port operators and so
on that kind of collaboration the
experts said is vital to stopping car
theft Rings Donna okay David aen thank
you the city of Belleville Ontario has
declared a state of emergency after
multiple overdoses in a short span of
time the city says emergency crews
responded to 17 overdoses in a 24-hour
period earlier this week 14 of them
happened over 2 hours on Tuesday
afternoon belleville's mayor warns the
addiction and Mental Health crisis is
putting an immense strain on Municipal
services and he wants provincial and
federal help has been taxing our
resources so whether it's fire that does
uh joint response with EMS and police
and um it's a a circumstance that
basically I don't see a solution for it
unless all governments get together no
deaths were reported from Tuesday's
overdoses and police say there was no
threat to the public but there have been
six more overdoses since then the US
Supreme Court heard arguments today on
whether former president Donald Trump
should be disqualified from running a
gain he is appealing a Colorado Supreme
Court decision to keep him off the
ballot in that State's primary because
he participated in an Insurrection on
January 6th 2021 as Jackson prco reports
the Supreme Court Justices seem deeply
skeptical that any state has the power
to remove a a candidate from the ballot
Traer trador it's Uncharted Territory
for the Supreme Court a fundamental test
of who can be president of the United
States the entire world saw the
Insurrection happen on television they
can't take him off the ballot for
something that he's not been proven
guilty of in December Colorado's Supreme
Court removed Donald Trump from the
state's primary
ballot ruling his role in the events of
January 6th disqualify him from the
presidency under an
anti-insurance after hearing arguments
on behalf of Colorado voters and Trump's
legal team the reason we're here is that
President Trump tried to disenfranchise
80 million Americans who voted against
him and the Constitution doesn't require
that he be given another chance this was
a riot it was not an Insurrection the
events were shameful criminal violent
all of those things but it did not
qualify as Insurrection the case will be
decided by the panel of nine justices
three of whom Trump appointed even the
liberal side of the bench seemed
uncomfortable with the implications of
upholding the Colorado case I think that
the question that you have to confront
is why a single state should decide who
gets to be president of the United
States I do think a victory for us will
in essence mean that Donald Trump will
not be on the ballot in the fall ahead
of the hearing we spoke with lawyer Eric
Olen who won the original Colorado
decision
he believes the court must deliver a
clear ruling to determine Trump's
eligibility once and for all it would be
very calaminus if they were to say it's
not our decision we're going to leave
this to poit to the political process it
may invite another January 6th if it's
Congress that not rather than the courts
who decide eligibility the man at the
center of it all was not in court but
Donald Trump expressed confidence he'll
be able to stay on the ballot you have
millions of people that are out there
wanting to vote and they happen to want
to vote for me the court must decide
this case quickly with Colorado's
primary just weeks away and for as much
as the justices may try to avoid getting
involved in the 2024 election they will
soon have to decide whether to take up
another Trump case determining whether
the former president is immune from
prosecution for his attempts to overturn
the last election Donna okay Jackson and
there was an important decision today
about President Joe Biden and whether he
can be prosecuted for the way he handled
classified documents before he became
president tell us about that Donna the
special Council investigating Biden
found that the president willfully
retained classified military and
National Security documents but he did
not break the law and will not face any
charges the investigator noted the case
is significantly different from the one
involving Donald Trump and that Biden
fully cooperated but the bad news for
Biden is that the investigation
highlighted significant memory lapses by
the 81-year-old president president
saying that during the course of the
year-long probe Biden could not recall
key dates including the death of his son
or the time when he was vice president
the White House responded to the special
Council saying that raising the memory
issues was not relevant to the
investigation Don right Jackson in
Washington thanks there has been a major
shakeup of Ukraine's military command
President Vladimir ziny has removed his
top General replacing him with the
commander of Ukraine's ground forces in
a social media post zinsky thanked
General Valerie zi for two years of
Defending Ukraine but said it's time for
someone new to lead with a different
approach zilinski says he proposed the
general who is popular with troops and
the public stay on as part of the team
Ukrainian troops have struggled to make
progress in the war with Russia and
tensions have mounted with the civilian
leadership voters in Pakistan are
anxiously awaiting the results of that
country's 12th general election people
stood in long lines to cast ballots in
an election that's been marred by
violence bombings and the imprisonment
of a popular party leader the government
suspended mobile phone service for the
day it says over security concerns
millions of Voters Inked their thumbs to
mark their ballots preliminary results
have been slow to come in but early
reports show leads for candidates from
the former prime minister Imran Khan's
party he's the leader who's in jail
Crystal ganing on the turbulent state of
politics in
Pakistan
81 with more than 120 million eligible
voters the election commission of
Pakistan can take up to two weeks to
declare a winner but that time may not
be
necessary this man Nazar shareif and his
Pakistan Muslim League party will likely
come out on top he's been prime minister
three times previously his main
Challenger is otherwise occupied Imran
KH is serving jail time for corruption
and brief of National Security but he is
still wildly popular Shar was also
kicked out of office and convicted of
corruption but he had his record cleared
enabling him to run
again I've been casting votes in
elections since 1970 says this man he
likes the older days better saying
families now struggle to pay their bills
and buy
food Pakistan is in an economic crisis
and is struggling with militant violence
on Wednesday there were two separate
strikes outside political party campaign
offices killing at least 22 people
fearing what would happen election day
the UN Human Rights Chief appealed to
authorities to ensure a free and fair
vote citing incidents of terrorism the
interior Ministry cut cell service for
the day critics said it was a way for
the caretaker government and indirectly
the military to influence the election
audio and video messages are popular as
the nation has low literacy
rates it's part of the reason Pakistan
allows parties to use symbols for voters
to recognize their candidates well we
don't know the outcome yet in the past
75 years no prime minister has served
their full five-year term Crystal Ganson
Global News
London you're vision and the virus that
causes covid coming up a concerning rise
in eye infections and symptoms to watch
for the pandemic is behind us now but
covid-19 is still with us and doctors
are raising the alarm about a growing
number of cases of the virus affecting
people's eyes they're still learning
about why and how it happens and how it
can affect Vision Mike drle
explains as anybody who's had viral
conjunctivitis known more commonly as as
pink eye can attest it's contagious it
passed on really quick like within a
week the whole house had it even so
Diego biso and his family weren't overly
concerned so they asked their pharmacist
who told them pink eye but a little over
a week after starting antibiotics
Diego's dad's eyes were still dark red
and the 18-year-old looked like he'd
been in a fight because he got infected
as well it looked like I was Rocky I
couldn't open my eyes for basically 5
days concern turned to worry and after a
visit to the optometrist they were
stunned to learn the goop in their eyes
came back positive for covid so these
are all cases that we had in one day
look right over here Dr Ken mandakas
says at its peak he was getting four to
five cases a day and is now seeing a
spike in new cases The Strain is viral
like traditional pink eye but it's more
aggressive than anything he's ever seen
unlike the other viruses that we've seen
in the past this one is causing a lot of
inflammation of the eye a lot of
swelling of the tissue of the eye
blurred vision pain and it's causing
bleeding in the white of the eye so
instead of it being uh a pink eye in
appearance it's actually red eye um like
a hemorrhaging type of appearance when
asked the Ontario optometrist
Association says it's certainly aware of
an increase in serious viral eye
infections and they did post some
information on their website earlier in
the season however unless they do a
broader social media campaign
information on this issue is spreading
word of mouth so optom
telling pharmacists what to look for
this is a patient who is obviously more
advanced we see a lot more uh
hemorrhaging and redness of the eyes the
treatment for these aggressive cases
includes an eyewash followed by
prednizone drops and symptoms can last
for months some patients were left with
uh spots on their cornea that would then
lead to glare and Halos around lights
that we now are treating for a longer
term like let's say two to 3 months
Diego belisimo is getting better but
some of the side effects haven't gone
away he says he's learned learned a
valuable lesson when it comes to his
eyes he's seeing his optometrist Mike
drle Global News
Toronto still ahead Iceland declares a
state of emergency as that volcano
erupts
[Music]
again Iceland is under a state of
emergency after lava from a volcanic
eruption damaged a key hot water
pipeline it is the third time this
volcano has erupted since December
sending Fountains of lava up to 80 M
High more than 20,000 people have lost
hot water and heat and there are
concerns the lava could reach a nearby
power plant a river of lava is also
flowing over a Road near the Blue Lagoon
Spa triggering an evacuation order at
one of Iceland's most popular tourist
attractions medalists at this Summer's
Paris Olympics will also take home part
of a famous French Monument each metal
holds an 18 G hexagonal chunk of iron
from the Eiffel Tower built in 1889 some
of the tower's original iron was removed
and preserved during Renovations in the
20th century just over 5,000 of the
medals were made for this year's Olympic
Games Oasis Of Peace next how Jews and
Palestinians coexist in this Israeli
[Music]
Village it's hard to see much hope in
the Middle East right now but there is
still a place where Israelis and
Palestinians are living in peace it's
called NE Shalom a mixed Jewish and
Palestinian Village the only one of its
kind about halfway between Jerusalem and
Tel Aviv it was founded more than 50
years ago based on an Old Testament
prophecy that my people shall dwell in
an oasis of Peace Danielle hamam Jin
visited to find out what lessons can be
learned
there if you listen to them it's not
always
obvious
which child is Palestinian which one is
Jewish and that's the whole point
everyone here has to learn both Hebrew
and Arabic welcome to the Village of NE
Shalom or as the other half calls it
Salam it means aasis of Peace it's not a
bubble I think this is the only way we
can survive
here there are no mosques no synagogues
no churches here home to a 100 families
they came wanting to live alongside one
another key to the success of this
Village and it's a strict rule
maintaining an equal number of Jewish
and Palestinian
families founded in the 1970s The
Village was the vision of a monk Bruno
husar it sits on land gifted by the
nearby Monastery it was empty no no
houses no Tre is nothing Nava sun and
shine was one of the first to move here
what's the
secret to share power
equally she now runs a school for peace
that has seen tens of thousands come
through its doors on it people who live
here and people who graduated our
programs they have this ability and it's
a rare ability today to see the
complexity to see both sides to
feel empathy but not everyone is a fan
of their ethos the school for peace was
gutted in an arson attack and right-wing
groups were behind this graffiti death
to Arabs it said okay you live together
Bravo but it's not something that can
coexist it's always the easy answer you
know it cannot work there is no way like
if you
tried Aya in green is Arab aava in white
is Jewish it's here it's possible I
think it's good and it helps us
understand each other it doesn't matter
like if we're Jewish or Arab we need to
all be
equal in addition to school lessons aava
learns Arabic in Bernadette's kitchen
she's an Arab Christian woman who's
lived here for 30 years she's a good
student on the edge of the village
coexistence even in Death from the
cemetery you can see the second
generation of homes that were
built the waiting list to join the
village is a long one on both
sides Daniel hamam J Global News in the
village of n
Shalom
Salam and that is global national for
this Thursday I'm Donna freezen
tonight's your Canada is an aerial view
of Green Bay New Finland and Labrador
thanks for watching me through garer
will be at the anchor desk tomorrow and
I will see you again on Monday
[Music]
bye-bye